[Musik]
zwei Brüder eine Leidenschaft und ein
Name den die ganze Welt kennt wir haben
bekanntes gerade wie mercedes-bz leider
nicht die gleichen Umsätze gelb süß
hochprozentig
[Musik]
Eierlikör wenn ich jemanden sage wo ich
arbeite kommt jedes Mal ach das ist doch
Eier
verporten
ein genialer Slogan denn es geht ums Ei
und nur ums Ei es hat aus der Familie
eines fläischen Händlers eine Dynastie
gemacht deren Erfolg basiert auf einem
einzigen Produkt dem
Eierlikör und das seit fast anderthalb
[Musik]
Jahrhunderten
die Brüder Dirk und William verporten
Teilen eine große Liebe sie ist massiv
schwer und laut ihre
h wenn die beiden in der Eifel unterwegs
sind ganz in der Nähe der Firma in Bonn
geht es mal nicht um Likör sondern nur
um den Fahrtwind im Gesicht den
dröhnenden Sound in den Ohren und die PS
unterm
Hintern sie S Generation der
[Musik]
eierlikördynastie William verporten
leitet das Unternehmen heute sein
jüngerer Bruder Dirk ist
Teilhaber ihr Vater Viktor sorgte dafür
dass Eierlikör das Getränk des
Wirtschaftswunders wurde zu Gast in
jedem Wohnzimmer im lekörglas und im
Fernsehen
ach sieh mal den haben wir ja auch
wporten Eierlikör ja genau das Richtige
für den gemütlichen fernseherabend also
ich erinnere sehr wohl dass der fah
natürlich den einschaltplan hatte wann
welche Werbung gebucht wurde geschaltet
wurde und da war natürlich ein Muss dass
wir guckten ob die auch wirklich für das
viele Geld was die damals verlangt haben
ob wir dann auch wirklich von vorne bis
hinten dabei waren und hab natürlich
drauf gefiebert und gewachtet veren
Eierlikör und das Wichtigste dabei ist
das ei
ei verorten veren alleren verporten
meist gekaufter Eierlikör der
Welt die Werbung zeigte Wirkung kaum ein
Kaffeekränzchen ohne
eierliörchen die Zeiten änderten sich
und mit ihnen die Werbung verpochten mit
Limo und natürlich
pur heute muss man sich in der Firma
schon etwas mehr einfallen lassen
Eierlikör bleibt halt Eierlikör nicht
gerade ein hippes
[Musik]
Modegetränk wenn ich mit meinen Freunden
über verporten gesprochen habe haben
viele gesagt ach das trinkt ja meine Oma
immer darum sollen jetzt Isabel Kornau
und Laura Vogel dabei helfen dass aus
dem Likörchen zum Kaffeeklatsch ein
cooler Long Drink für den Abend
wird
und der heißt dann z.B yellow red sweete
Flirt oder Bahia
Splash und dann muss alles auch noch
über die richtigen Kanäle beworben
[Musik]
werden die Herausforderung für uns halt
von diesem Vorurteil W zu kommmen dass
es halt nur für ältere Leute ein Getränk
ist und da halt so eine gewisse Dynamik
und Vielfalt reinzubringen dass auch
jüngere Leute
anspricht aber natürlich soll der
dynamische Drink auch der
Stammkundschaft schmecken ein
schwieriger
Spagat am Anfang der Geschichte steht
das Ei genauer gesagt viele
Eier sehr viele
Eier bis zu 1,2 Millionen werden am Tag
hier in Bonn angeliefert sie kommen aus
der
das heißt einem Umkreis von rund 200 km
sagt die Firma stammen aus Bodenhaltung
und sind Güte Klasse
A nicht ist sensibler als das Ei den
insofern verlassen uns nicht auf eine
eisuppe angeliefert im Tankwagen von
Belgien sondern wir wollen das lieber
selber
tun auch bei dieser Masse an Eiern
reicht ein einziges aus um eine ganzege
Eierlikör zu verderben darum wird aus
jeder Palette ein Ei entnommen und im
firmeneigenen Labor untersucht bevor
alles weiter verarbeitet
[Musik]
wird hier begann die Geschichte in
Heinsberg bei Aachen dorthin verschlug
es vor rund 200 Jahren die flämische
Familie
verporten
in der Hochstraße eröffnete der Sohn der
Familie in den 1870er Jahren ein
Geschäft für Spirituosen und kolonial
waren der Name des Gründers Eugen
verporten der hat eine gesamte
Bandbreite gehabt an spiritosen und da
hieß es auch immer da wäre Wein
abgefüllt worden und wenn der wenn der
umkippt und wurde Essig dann gabürich
auch Gurken das liegt relativ nah spe
Margarine Tabak bei Eugen verporten gab
es so ziemlich alles was man zum Leben
brauchte das Herz des Unternehmens war
aber die likfabrik hier stellte Eugen
auch den Eierlikör her das Rezept hatte
seine Familie aus der flandrischen
Heimat mit nach Heinsberg gebracht
interessanterweise verkaufte er den
Likör in der Hochstraße schon damals
unter dem Namen
Advokat te hat erstmal gar nichts mit
Eiern zu tun sie spielt am Amazonas hier
so heißt es entdeckten niederländische
Seefahrer ein Getränk dass die
Ureinwohner aus einer seltsamen
Baumfrucht herstellten gelb süß und
hochprozentig
Hauptzutat Avocado die Niederländer
liebten es Versuche die Frucht in der
Heimat anzubauen scheiterten leider man
suchte nach einem Ersatz und landete
beim Eidotter von der Avocado blieb aber
der flämische Name
Advokat in Heinsberg liefen die
Geschäfte gut für die Familie verporten
Eugens Söhne gründeten in der Nähe
eigene
Unternehmen Heinrich eröffnete wie sein
Vater ein Geschäft für likur und
Kolonialwaren Josef verporten verkaufte
unter anderem Grundnahrungsmittel
und Philip wurde
Kohlenhändler doch die Zeiten waren
schwierig für Kaufleute das Kohlenlager
Schloss bald wieder und auch Heinrich
musste seinen Laden aufgeben nur ihren
Eierlikör verkaufte die Familie nach wie
vor aber dann brach der Erste Weltkrieg
aus nach dem Krieg besetzten die
Franzosen das Rheinland das Problem für
die likörfamilie auf die Einfuhr der
Rohstoffe musste sie nun Zölle bezahlen
und das war nicht alles die Besetzung
des Rheinlands hat enorme Probleme für
Unternehmen gebracht man musste ja alles
was in rin hergestellt werden auch dann
außerhalb die Zone ausführen damit man
außerhalb von rein verkaufen konnte das
war schon ziemlich auf aufwendig Eugens
Enkel Wilhelm stand vor einer riskanten
Entscheidung um weiter erfolgreich
handeln zu können musste er raus aus dem
besetzten
reheinland auf nach Berlin in den 20er
Jahren lebten hier Menschen hier tobte
das Leben und mit Einführung der
Rentenmark
1923 ging es vielen auch wirtschaftlich
wieder
[Musik]
besser von Schöneberg aus Vertrieb
Wilhelm verporten mit einem
Geschäftspartner tafellikör und
holländische
Spezialitäten da war mein Großvater
sicherlich in den 20 Jahren mit seinen
Produkten an der richtigen Stelle und am
richtigen Ort her vor allem eines kam
dem likörhändler zute das wilde
Partyleben in der Nacht es wurde getanzt
hemmungslos gefeiert und vor allem auch
getrunken Dienst ist Dienst Schnaps ist
Schnaps aber für Willie verporten
gehörte beides zusammen und unser Opa
Willi auch genannt der schöne Willi war
viel unterwegs und hat dazu gesehen dass
er den barbetreibern und den Bardamen da
die richtigen Spirituosen zugeschustert
hat damit sie seine freuen Kundinnen und
Kunden wurden die wiederum dann an die
Konsumenten ausgegeben wurden also der
war viel unterwegs und musste musste
Türklinken
putzen
1921 heiratete der schöne Willie die
Berlinerin i matichock ein Jahr später
wurde ihr Sohn victtor
geboren doch dann kam die
Wirtschaftskrise
Ende der 20er Jahre wurden Lebensmittel
zum Luxusgut Eier für Likör gab es in
Berlin nicht mehr die verportens
brauchten einen Ort an dem ihr Rohstoff
keine Mangelware war sie fanden ihn in
[Musik]
Niederbayern die Historikerin Dorit
Maria Kren leitet das Stadtarchiv in
Straubing in der Stadt an der Donau
eröffnete verporten in den 30er Jahren
eine
Zweigstelle es ist eine ungewöhnliche
Unternehmensgeschichte die hier in den
Regalen
lagert denn Firmenchef Wilhelm verporten
reiste nicht selbst nach Bayern sondern
schickte seine junge Ehefrau
ell sollte sich um den eiernachschub für
das Berliner Stammhaus kümmern doch
dabei blieb es nicht
wurde selbst zur
[Musik]
eierlikörpoduzentin Spurensuche in der
Straubinger
Innenstadt dabei helfen alte Baupläne
aus dem
Stadtarchiv hier auf dem Gelände
autohuses war früher eine
Brauerei
1936 standen Teile davon
leer porten hat offenbar e hier ein ja
geeignetes Objekt gefunden für ihre
eierlück
Produktion es ging nicht nur um die
Produktion von Eierlikör es ging um das
Überleben des gesamten
Familienunternehmens und
unternehmersgtin veren wurde zur
Unternehmerin undon den ZeitzeugInnen
die sie eben als als Chefin sage ich
jetzt und Mitarbeiterin erlebt haben die
haben gesagt dass sie wirklich äußerst
tatkräftig war auch humorvoll aber
wirklich diese diese und diese
energiegeladenheit für die damalige Zeit
war das sicherlich eine eine großartige
Leistung die sie da vor Ort mit dem
rekrutieren von MitarbeiterInnen von
Mitarbeitern und Räumlichkeiten anmieten
die sie da gestemmt hat ja ja das war
das war wirklich hut ab hut ab große
Frau Ehemann Willi blieb meist im
Berliner Stammhaus Sohn Viktor musste an
die Ostfront abgesehen vom Hausmeister
und ein paar Fahrern arbeiteten nur
Frauen in der Fabrik das wurde während
des Kriegs zu is Vorteil sie l nicht
unter den Abstellungen der Männer die
dann in den Krieg ziehen mussten ne was
ja oft viele Betriebe ja ganz zu
schaffen gemacht sondern die Frauen sind
ja da geblieben und haben hier weiterhin
geschafft dass if ver porten während des
Zweiten Weltkriegs im Keller der
ehemaligen Brauerei überhaupt Eierlikör
produzieren konnte verdankte sie
besonderen Umständen das war nicht
einfach irgendwie jetzt was was ich Eier
und Brandwein und Zucker in Massen zu
kaufen sondern die haben wirklich
Zuteilungen bekommen weil sie ein so ein
kriegswichtiges Produkt
erstellten kriegswichtig weil der
Eierlikör als Stärkungsmittel für die
verwundeten Soldaten galt während des
Krieges lieferte verporten darum
jährlich 2500 lit Eierlikör an das
Deutsche Rote
[Musik]
Kreuz hier im Keller überdauerte der
eierlikur so die Kriegsjahre doch
draußen stand die Welt an einem
Wendepunkt mit dem Einmarsch der
alliierten Streitkräfte in Deutschland
kündigte sich das Ende des Zweiten
Weltkriegs
an das Berliner Stammhaus war zerbomt
und auch in Straubing war Schluss mit
der Produktion von Eierlikör denn
zunächst prüften die Amerikaner ob das
Unternehmen nicht mit dem nazegime
verstrickt war wie überall in
Deutschland herrschten auch hier
chaotische Zustände Plünderungen
gehörten zum
Alltag es hat auch die Firma verporten
getroffen es haben die Leid natürlich
gewusst dass hier was Gutes produziert
wird und Zeitzeugen haben berichtet eben
dass hier im setzkeller knöcheltief der
eierlücke See war und dass die Leute im
V allem die Altstadtbewohner eben sich
eimerweise diesen eierlücke aber auch
die Soldaten die amerikanischen Soldaten
sich diesen eierlücker davon geschleppt
haben die amerikanischen GI feierten das
Kriegsende mit verportens
Eierlikör auch die Familie von Dorit
Maria Kren hatte sich eine Schüssel
sichern können diese ganzen Frauen sind
um den Küchentisch gesessen und haben
mit den suppenlöffeln diesen eierlücke
ausgelöffelt und sie S mit jedem Löffel
beschwipster worden und lustiger worden
und von daher ist Kriegsende und
eierlükör für meine Mama und wie gesagt
für meine Oma war das immer eine
Verbindung nach der Überprüfung des
Unternehmens gab die amerikanische
Militärregierung ihr Okay verporten
durfte wieder
Produzieren von nun an führte die
Familie den Betrieb zu dritt denn auch
Sohn Viktor kehrte aus der
Kriegsgefangenschaft zurück und kam nach
Straubing
doch das Firmengelände wurde bald zu
klein und die Lieferwege in die großen
Städte waren zu
weit heute steht die Firmenzentrale von
verporten in
Bonn und dort hat
is Enkel William gerade ein Problem die
Maschinen stehen
still wenn der Produktionsablauf stockt
kann das schnell zu einem größeren
Schaden werden allem wenn man es mit
sensiblen Eiern zu tun
hat heute kann der Chef aufatmen die
Störung ist behoben die Eier rollen
wieder im Akkord die hightechanlage ist
extrem empfindlich schon bei einer
kleinen Unregelmäßigkeit schaltet sie
sich
ab was war den was war denn der Grund
für die Störung aneinander
geklebt kleine Ursache große
Wirkung william verporten ist allein
verantwortlicher Chef des Unternehmens
aber die tägliche Auszeit am Rhein muss
sein in mir stecken 100% reheinländer
weil ich bin ja nun der erste der in
Bonn geboren wurde der Vater ist
Berliner die Mutter ist Münchnerin und
ich war das erste Kind in
Bonn dass das so kam war nicht
selbstverständlich seine Großeltern und
sein Vater in Straubing mussten eine
Entscheidung treffen was war der beste
Platz für das Unternehmen Berlin lag
nach dem Krieg mitten in der Sowjetzone
und kam nur als Zweigstelle in Frage der
Hauptsitz der Firma musste zentraler
liegen dort wo jetzt die Musik
[Musik]
spielte wir hatten drei Standorte h neus
es gab Frankfurt und es gab Bonn und
Bonn wurde bundeshaupstand und dann hat
der Vater die Entscheidung getroffen
nach Bonn zu gehen
1949 hielt die Politik der jungen
Republik hier
Einzug Diplomaten Beamte Politiker das
kleine Bonn wurde zum Hotspot dann
erkläre ich die erste Sitzung des
Bundestages der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland für
[Musik]
eröffnet am Bonner Verteilerkreis
errichtete verporten
1952 sein neues Firmengelände und der
Eierlikör wurde wieder zum Produkt aus
dem
[Musik]
Rheinland jetzt verorten in der Stad
mitten im bevölkerungsreichsten
Bundesland und irgendwie auch am Nabel
der Welt wenn irgendwelche Politiker
dann hier empfangen wurden da erinnere
ich mich z.B dran dass man dann auf de
markt ging und guckte dann halt wenn
wenn die Autos dann anfuhren od die
Personen dann oben auf die Treppe
stiegen dann war dann halt bon eben eine
besondere
Stadt sogar der mächtigste Mann der Welt
bekam die eierlikörfabrik zu
Gesicht
wenn dann so sternförmig die weißen
Mäuse das waren damals die Polizisten
mit den weißen Helmen mit ihren stolzen
butterrädern der Kolonne vorfunden und
hinterher kam dann die schwarzen
Limousinen John F Kennedy ist hier um
den um unseren unseren Verteilerkreis
gefahren worden haben wir oben auf dem
Dach gestanden hier auf unserem
zweigeschossen Gebäude haben von hier
oben mit beobachten
können vorbei die Zeit in der
bayerischen Provinz verporten war jetzt
mittendrin das war schon das war schon
Hauch der großen weiten Welt ganz
bestimmt ja bon knüpfte Beziehungen mit
Staaten rund um den
Globus und Diplomaten aus aller
Herrenländer zogen in die Nachbarschaft
des
eierlikörpoduzenten die Stadt hat sich
insofern verändert als wir
bundeshauptstattt waren es waren ja
viele Nationalitäten plötzlich hier
viele Fremde auch in der Stadt das
nutzten die verportens ausländische
Delegationen interessierten sich für die
moderne Produktionsstätte am Bonner
Verteilerkreis neben diesen
diplomatischen besuchen gab es immer
auch Besuchsprogramme was lag da näher
aus auch den Eierlikör Fabrikanten zu
besuchen doch Besucher kam nicht nur zum
Eierlikör der eierlikur ging nun von
Bonn aus auch raus in die
Welt
[Musik]
in alle Herren Länder wurde exportiert
und das Geschäft wurde immer weiter
ausgedehnt auch in Übersee trank man
jetzt
verporten damals wie heute meine ich ja
auch dass deutsche Nahrungsmittel einen
ausgesprochen hohen Stellenwert haben
und man schon wertschätzt und weiß um
die Qualität die da aus Lucky old
Germany verfrachtet wurde und heute auch
noch wird
immerhin das Rezept für den Likör ist
immer noch dasselbe wie vor 150
Jahren die Produktion sieht allerdings
etwas anders aus am Anfang steht der
sogenannte
eieraufschlag hier wird das Eigelb vom
Eiweiß getrennt denn das wird für den
Eierlikör nicht gebraucht diese Maschine
schafft unglaubliche 120.000 Eier pro
Stunde
vor 50 Jahren war das
undenkbar damals wurde das alles noch
von Hand gemacht das war ja noch alles
ganz einfach und primitiv
damals da schwamm das Eiweiß in bahen
und wo es wurde mit der Schöpfkelle
wurde der eidotte der reingefallen ist
aus Versehen der wurde rausgeschöpft und
dann rüber
geangelt ein schlechtes Ei da vielleicht
drin war das wurde dann rausgeschöpft
das könnte man heute nicht mehr bezahlen
es wäre auch vom hygienischen Standpunkt
her war das war das
zweitklassig aber was passiert denn nun
mit dem
Eiweiß ein Drittel vom Ei ist nur das
eidotte und das wollen wir eigentlich
nur haben aber durch das Aufschlagen
haben natürlich zwe Drittel Eiweiß das
müssen wir auch und das vololg bringen
das müssen wir auch wieder vermarkten
sonst stimmt die Kalkulation nicht
immerhin fallen täglich bis zu 35000 l
Eiweiß an wird als Sprühschaum verkauft
z.B als Grundlage für beses
cremefüllungen und Schokoküsse damit
macht verporten rund 15% seines
Umsatzes nur das Gelbe vom Ei wird zu
Likör in geschlossenen Tanks wird es mit
Vodka und geheimen Zutaten zu einer
Emulsion vermischt das genaue Rezept
hält die Familie seit 150 Jahren unter
Verschluss
schon bald wurde klar der Umzug in die
junge Hauptstadt war die richtige
Entscheidung hier ließ ich mit dem
Eierlikör prächtig verdienen denn
gefeiert wurde immer
[Musik]
irgendwo es gab immer wieder den den
Bonner Presseball und da hat natürlich
ver schon zugesehen dass die Marke da
präsent war und bei den bei den Tombula
Gewinn immer reinzufällig mit mit
Angeboten und und und verschenkt wurde
die Elter war natürlich in Bonn mit
vielen befreundet
und
gab dann auch Genscher der bei uns dann
ein oder andere Mal auf dem Fest war
oder auch andere Politiker es war auch
damals die Partyzeit und im alten
Elternhaus hatten wir auch ein Partyraum
eine Kegelbahn und da war es dann schon
ganz lustig ja
ell verporten hatte das Unternehmen
schon kurz nach dem Umzug an ihren Sohn
Viktor
übergeben er sollte das likörimerium in
die Zukunft führen Vater hatte immer
eine Krawatte an immer Jackett immer
akkurat er kam nachmittags bei Hitze 30
35° das spielt alles keine Rolle er kam
im leichten Jackett und hat uns also
gezeigt es ist doch überhaupt nicht warm
ich weiß gar nicht was ihr
wollt brhilde fassber arbeitete Jahre im
Unternehmen und war lange Chefsekretärin
von Vikor
verporten wenn Herr Viktor verpochen ins
Haus kam dann war sein erster Gang
eigentlich die Produktion dann wurde mit
dem Betriebsleiter gesprochen dem einen
oder anderen
Mitarbeiter und dann ging er langsam ins
Bürogebäude bis er dann wirklich in
seinem Büro in der obersten Etage
sprich dann bei mir war das dauerte oft
sehr sehr
lange victtor verporten war der
Patriarch des Unternehmens das er 47
Jahre leitete sein Sohn William hat
viele Jahre mit ihm zusammen
gearbeitet er hat grundsätzlich Papier
aufgehoben was irgendwo auf dem Hof
rumflog um einfach zu demonstrieren
darauf lege ich Wert und D haben andere
natürlich auch gesehen Menschens Kinder
wenn der das schon macht dann muss ich
das vielleicht auch mal tun
er war ein sehr sparsamer Mensch wenn er
also durch die Büros ging und das Licht
brannte noch dann wurde überall hat er
uns immer das Licht
ausgeknipst unter Viktors Führung wuchs
die Firma konstant man war erfolgreich
das weckte Begehrlichkeiten es sind
schon an uns herangetragen worden von
größeren spürte osenfirma Firma zu
kaufen wir hatten ja schon ich weiß
nicht wahrscheinlich 20 Mal verkaufen
können äh aber natürlich das Erbe der
Generation vorher weiter zuu verfolgen
ist schon wichtig das ist eigentlich
immer wieder abgelehnt worden das kam
gar nicht in Frage wir verbochten ein
sehr bedeutendes Beispiel von so einer
Familienunternehmen wo man denkt man
fühlt sich auch selbst anders Verantwort
für sein Eigentum als vielleicht in ein
Unternehmen wo sehr stark
menageorientiert entschieden wird aber
natürlich müssen sich auch
Familienunternehmen wie jedes ander
Markt behaupten und das hieß für
verporten ein Name ein Produkt
[Musik]
Eierlikör der Firmenchef setzte alles
auf eine
Karte Vater hat sich halt konzentriert
auf eine Marke und hat nicht einen
Bauchladen an verschiedenen sposen
hergestellt sondern eine Marke und die
Marke richtig zu machen und ist heute
das Positive das gr nur verporten als
die Marke gibt in der Kategorie
eiligör doch an anderer Stelle war der
Chef durchaus aufgeschlossen für
Experimente der Senior hatte
grundsätzlich sage ich jetzt mal der
hatte grundsätzlich das letzte Wort klar
ne der hat uns alle befragt und der
steht einmal vor unserem Schreibtisch
das werde ich nie vergessen dann hatte
er eine gipsflasche das war eine
glockenflasche da stellt er die Flasche
hin und sagt was haltet er dann von der
Flasche boah hab gesagt nee so ein umel
um Gottes Willen sieht ja verheerend
aus die ist nachher gelaufen die
glockenflasche er hatte Recht vor allem
zu Ostern und Weihnachten wurde die
Flasche zum
Klassiker rund 50 Millionen Euro Umsatz
macht verporten heute nach eigenen
Angaben im Jahr das ist die Ware die vom
Labor freigben wur also die Abfüllung
ist heute morgen freigegeben worden und
morgen geht's auf die Flasche B okay
destilaturmeister Bernhard rot ist dafür
verantwortlich dass jedes Glas Likör so
schmeckt wie es schmecken soll einm frei
ja 12 Eidotter stecken in jedem Liter
Likör rohe Eier ein empfindliches
[Musik]
Produkt es besteht der Verdacht dass sie
Dioxin belastet sind uns liegen interne
Mitteilungen aus den Niederlanden vor
die den Nachweis von fibronierern aus
den Niederlanden ist einer
stichprobenuntersuchung der Bundeswehr
in Süddeutschland war jedes siebte Ei
mit seinen Mengen belastet das wäre
verherend wenn wir mit mit irgendeinem
Skandal in Verbindung gebracht würden
das wäre eminent das dann könnte ich ja
morgen ab morgen Urlaub machen Rest des
Lebens dass so etwas bisher nicht
passiert ist liegt auch an der peniblen
Kontrolle im im firmeneigenen Labor das
Ei muss zuerst auf die Waage dann wird
es vermessen je höher das Ei weiß desto
frischer das
Ei der Computer gleicht Gewicht und
eiweißhöhe ab außerdem werden bei jedem
Produktionsschritt mikrobiologische
Untersuchungen
[Musik]
gemacht die Farbe des eidotters hängt
vom Hühnerfutter ab mit einem Farbfächer
prüft das Labor ob der Lieferant die
Vorgaben eingehalten
nur so ist sichergestellt dass der
Eierlikör immer die gleiche Farbe
hat zurück in die 70er der Eierlikör war
zum Klassiker geworden für den jetzt
auch Promis Werbung
machten wir haben ja damals auch
bekannte Schauspieler gehabt die für uns
tvwerbung gemacht haben allen voran
ge liebe kleine Frau wie du
Tom süß wie W mit dreal verporten
ver Cola und verp
cognp damals ganz ganz hoch angesehen
war war natürlich auch Peter Kraus Hall
jetztber mein
[Musik]
Talent Peter Kraus war unser Idol und
der kam jetzt im Fernsehen mach also für
Diema für die man tätig war einmal so
ein so und
ein ja da war man schon
stolz doch die genialste Idee war wohl
die mit dem Slogan denn den bekam man
einfach nicht mehr aus dem
Ohr dabei war die Melodie alles andere
als neu ein Schlager aus den
40ern
soweit ich erinnere war das war das
unsere damalige Kölner Werbeagentur die
uns diesen diese Namensverwandtschaft
mit dem a Maria ver porten näher
gebracht hat und der Vater fand das
genial und hat das hat das relativ
schnell
aufgegriffen bis heute zahlt die Firma
Lizenzgebühren für den
Schlager immer wieder gab's gab's
kreative Werbeagentur die wir hier haben
kommen und gehen sehen haben immer
wieder versucht komplett mit dem Eisen
Besen alle wegzukehren sagen wir haben
jetzt was ganz was Neues und wir haben
das Rad neu erfunden also das Rad haben
wir schon einigermaßen am am Wagen
gelassen und zugesehen dass man es neu
steuert aber neu austariert aber nicht
gänzlich gänzlich aufgibt dadurch haben
wir heute ein Bekanntheitsgrad von 93
95% gestützt was sich jeder wünschen
würde
beayerlikör war ein Getränk für jede
Gelegenheit und jedes
Alter der eierl hat in den 70er J eine
große Rolle gespielt er war in jedem
Haushalt vertreten die
Flasche stand auf dem Tisch wenn Kaffee
getrunken wurde zum Kuchen gab es immer
ein
eierlikörchen trotz seiner 20% Alkohol
galt der Eierlikör als
familientauglich sogar Kinder leckten
heimlich schon mal die Gläschen aus
stand do Weihnachten grundsätzlich als
Flasche unter Weihnachtsbaum also ohne
ohne die Flasche unter Weihnachtsbaum
das christk nicht Ansegeln das war
völlig klar unsere Mutter hat viel
gekocht viel gebacken es gab oft ein
Dessert mit verporten über Früchte über
Vanilleeis und das haben wir schon sehr
gelebt wichtig war natürlich auch immer
dass die Flasche wenn sie dann kreiste
als Flasche zu erkennen war mit dem mit
dem runden Logo und nicht verbremt in
irgendeine Karaffe neutral umgefüllt
wurde das ging gar nicht in den 90er
Jahren bahnte sich bei verporten der
Generationswechsel an vor Willam der
älteste übernahm immer mehr
Verantwortung vom
Senior demahc ich glaub für die erste
für den erste aussung für die
Verkaufsleiter reicht das so Vater hat
das mit dem Internet das hat er nicht so
richtig für Bar genommen das wollte auch
wofür dieser eher in strichgut ich weiß
do dieser dieser Bark auf der Rückseite
wie es hieß plötzlich das wäre jetzt
Usus und das wäre förderlich beim
Verkauf das hat er nicht so richtig
eingesehen vor 30 Jahren schon während
der Schulzeit hatten seine Söhne im
Betrieb gejobt und kannten die Abläufe
ich habe ja auch mal so ein paar Wochen
in der Produktion mal mit verbracht und
das war schon lustig man wird
zurückgehalten mit Taschengeld das Flos
ja nicht in Strömen insofern musste man
sich das verdienen und das war ein
harter Job das war von morgens früh bis
spät nachmittags da wusste man schon was
man getan hat die ehemalige
Chefsekretärin Brunhilde Fassbender
hatte auch privat engen Kontakt zur
Familie und kennt die beiden Söhne seit
ihrer
Jugend
[Musik]
deren unterscheidet sich glaube ich in
seinem ganzen Wesen von dem älteren
Bruder er ist viel spontaner gewesen
mein Bruder der ist der ist gerne unter
Menschen der lädt do gerne ein ein
lieber Bruder kann auch gut Witze
erzählen er ist graddienig macht Spaß
mit dem unterwegs se also der ist ist
ist kein Langweiler ja und ist 10 Jahre
älter als
ich beide Brüder arbeiteten zeitweise
gemeinsam im Familienunternehmen William
im Export Dirk im Marketing doch als die
Firmenübernahme näher rückte war klar
nur einer kann das Familienunternehmen
als Geschäftsführer leiten daran ließ
Patriarch Viktor keinen
Zweifel mein Vater war gesagt es kann
immer nur einer an der Pinne am Ruder
stehen sonst weiß das Schiff nicht wo es
hinläuft also zwei zwei Steuermänner das
ging nicht und da ich das nicht war und
ich nicht die zweite Geige spielen
wollte habe ich mich dazu entschlossen
eigene Form zu gründen und zu
menagchen doch auch mit seinen eigenen
Firmen blieb Dirk verporten in der
Getränkebranche er handelte mit Sirup
und gründete einen importhandel für
ausländische
Spirituosen am Unternehmen verporten
hält er knapp ein der
Anteile am liebsten zieht es den
Geschäftsmann in die Natur er liebt die
eifelwälder hat hier einen zweiten
Wohnsitz mir fallen no mal die besten
Ideen ein wenn ich in natur bin und da
habe ich dann Ruhe und da stört mich
keiner und dann läuft keine E-Mail und
kein Handy so ist das
ja bei seinem neuesten Unternehmen kamen
ihm die Erfahrungen seiner Vorfahren
zute
ein Dachbodenfund so erzählt er hat ihn
zurück in die Geschichte seiner Familie
geführt wir hatten im Elternhaus hatten
wir hatten wir ein großes Elternhaus in
Bonn am Venusberg und da war ein großer
Speicher den wir eigentlich so gut wie
nie aufgesucht haben und irgendwann
sagte meine Mutter da oben ist noch ein
Überseekoffer und dann habe ich vor
vielen Jahren den Ü Koffer mal
rausgeholt der alte Koffer hörte iell
verporten darin habe er ein
handgeschriebenes Rezept für einen
Kräuterlikör gefunden den seine
Großmutter einst kreiert habe erzählt er
als
verporten starb war Dirk gerade mal 3
Jahre alt zu ihren Ehren habe er den
likur neu aufgelegt nannte ihn aber
nicht verporten sondern
Hirschrudel ich möchte gerne neben
Deutschland auch ausländische Märkte
forsieren da wün mir dass wir in den
nächsten Jahren die eine Million
Flaschen vielleicht international dann
auch schaffen die Entscheidung sein
eigenes Ding zu machen fand ich sehr gut
ich könnte mir nämlich vorstellen dass
so wenn Brüder im Unternehmen sind dass
das auch nicht so auf Dauer
erfolgreiches Unternehmen
ist bis zu seinem Tod ließ victtor
verporten es sich nicht nehmen
regelmäßig in die Firma zu
kommen die Übergabe erfolgte nicht von
einem Tag auf den anderen viele Jahre
hatten Vater und Sohn zuvor Seite an
Seite
gearbeitet ich habe ja anfangs hier
gerade in diesem Büro das Vaters altes
Büro hatte ich anfangs hier ein zweiten
Schreibtisch stehen will und mein Vater
saßen ja 14 Jahre in dem Büro zusammen
das hätte ich wahrscheinlich mein Vater
nicht ausgehalten Vater und ich wir
waren relativ gleich was zum Teil schön
war zum Teil aber auch nicht immer ganz
gut funktionierte
dann knallt halt auch mal ich habe eine
ganze Menge natürlich an Telefonaten und
Besprechungen hier im Büro miterlebt
insofern war das ein gleitender Übergang
der Übergang war sehr wahrscheinlich für
beide nicht so einfach weil es waren ja
auch wieder Generationen die sich jetzt
zusammenraufen
[Musik]
mussten seit 2003 leitet William
verporten das Familienunternehmen
alleine ich habe mich natürlich lange
Zeit immer wieder dran erinnert dass man
hätte jetzt ganz gerne noch mal Rad
geholt man muss natürlich dann auch
irgendwann selber schwimmen
lernen ja also Vater war ja mein bester
Freund und auch unter William bleibt es
dabei verporten produziert Eierlikör
sonst
nichts aber natürlich hat man hier in
Bonn auch neue Ideen arbeitet mit
süßwarenherstellern Bäckereien und
tiefkühlfirmen zusammen
aber der meiste Eierlikör kommt nach wie
vor in die Flasche seit kurzem auch in
zwei neuen Geschmacksrichtungen psig
maracuya und
[Musik]
Amaretto täglich gehen rund 150 000
Flaschen likö in unterschiedlichen
Größen übers Band wie viel Liter das
sind verrät das Unternehmen
nicht geliefert wird in 30 Länder der
Welt eine Dynastie die ihren Erfolg
einem einzigen Produkt verdankt ein
Risiko das weiß auch
William bei uns muss wie beim türschlag
vom rolls-rous muss das satt ins Schloss
fallen darf nicht klappern das Etikett
muss sitzen die Ausstattung muss sitzen
das Produkt innen drin darf überhaupt
keine Diskussion ausführen da müssen wir
einfach der Beste sein aber gutes
Aussehen alleine reicht
nicht als Markenartikler muss man nicht
nur gut sein muss auch gut drüber
sprechen damit es auch dritte hören und
verinnerlichen und wahrnehmen und
weitersprechen allenen muss man den den
Konsumenten natürlich ansprechen und da
muss man state of art sein habt ihr
verporten schon mal gemischt 2004 gilt
das als mutig verporten lässt in der
Werbung Leien vor die Fernsehkamera auf
E mit
aufgefüt die wussten B nicht um was es
geht die war nur eingeladen können sich
vorstellen morgen Nachmittag für eine
Stunde Werbefernsehen aufzutreten für
eine bedeutende Spirituosenmarke mögen
sie spiritosen ja mög ich wunderbar sind
morgen eingeladen also den Geschmack
kann ich aber schlecht
beschreiben und dieses das war viel viel
glaubwürdiger als wenn er gesagt oh das
schmeckt aber gut das finde ich super
das kann ich empfehlen doch alles hat
seine Grenzen auch beim Eierlikör uns
wurde vorgeschlagen das war für die
damalige Zeit haben wir uns nicht
getraut was vielleicht man zu Hause tut
aber sich nicht dabei erwischen lassen
möchte das ausschlecken des Glases bis
zum Grund
das fand wir doch zu zu
zu ich will jetzt sagen ordinär aber das
fand wir doch zu zu dicht am am am
Konsumenten und haben das dann lieber
sein lassen der Spruch war D bei
verbochten geht man bis zum letzten das
haben wir nicht
genommen und es geht werbetechnisch auch
schon mal etwas
daneben wenn die Mädels sagen also was
habt denn da für ein heißes Luder mit
Spaghettiträgern rumrennen die sich nur
um die Männer bemü und versucht ständig
den Mädels ihre ihre ihre Freunde oder
ihre Ehemänner da abspenig zu machen und
bei der Gelegenheit völlig vergessen
wird um welche Marke es geht und handelt
ja dann ist mir spätest auf dem Holzweg
der produzierte Spot wurde gleich wieder
eingestampft kan auch wir lernen noch
dazu dass sind wir auf dem guten Weg ja
klar denn heute reicht Fernsehwerbung
längst nicht mehr aus um bekannt zu
seinen meh mehr in Online TV und wir
gehen mehr und mehr natürlich auch in
die Social Medias und da müssen auch
Instagram und wie sie alle heißen
bedienen ich denke in Sachen Social
Media hat der Chef wahrscheinlich nicht
so große Kompetenzen aber er vertraut
auch in uns dass wir da unser Bestes
geben man sollte so gesund sein und
schlau sein sich dafür Leute zu holen
die das dann machen weil dieser Mark ist
so schnell das kann man gar nicht
selber deshalb lässt verporten ein
junges Team ans
Ruder Isabel Kornau und Laura Vogel
beide Anfang 20 sind
mediengestalterinnen im kleinen
hauseigenen Studio produzieren sie Fotos
und Clips für soziale Netzwerke wie
Facebook und
Instagram sie setzen auch auf die
Werbung durch food
Blogger die Bloggerszene ist für uns
auch wichtig weil man dann halt explizit
diese Leute erreicht die gerne backen
oder kochen oder Desserts machen und man
dadurch halt das Publikum noch mal
erweitern kann deshalb ist der Eierlikör
mit seinen rund 150 Jahren jetzt online
z.B mit eigener Facebookseite
Rezeptideen für Kuchen und Cocktails
Clips Fotostrecken eine Community der
ztausende Folgen auch der
Chef der freut sich wenn er von den
jungen KollegInnen noch etwas lernen
kann vor allem wenn man so auch neue
Kunden
[Musik]
erreicht William und Dirk jedenfalls
machen sich keine Sorgen um die Zukunft
ihrer
eierlikördynastie ich glaube dass es
eikür in 50 Jahren noch geben wird wir
halten das Produkt am Leben und wir
bauen das aus und momentan hat Eik per
se gesprochen richtig
renissance doch wie sieht's mit der
nächsten Generation aus natürlich
wünscht sich der Chef dass er die
Verantwortung irgendwann an Sohn oder
Tochter übergeben
kann bis heute ist es noch nicht
ausgeguckt wer wer man was macht also
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt heute noch nicht
genau was die beiden machen wollen ich
bin mal gespannt ich bin ja noch
knusprig und Jung insofern habe ich ja
noch viel Zeit mit das zu belegen aber
es ein gewaltiger
anspor und dann würde die sechste
Generation hier am Bonner Verteilerkreis
an den Start
mit einem Produkt das seit 150 Jahren
den Erfolg der Familiendynastie
[Musik]
sichert